you mention schopenhauer which is
excellent um i feel like the
idea of nothing more fundamental than
the will
the inner nature of everything i love
that one i love
the one eye of the world that looks out
from every creature
i love that one as well so
you know given given the case of
schopenhauer and yourself i mean
we now have significantly more
than 100 years ago had especially
thousands of years ago for talking like
the vedic rishis and stuff
we have significantly more access um
especially under our revelation of
quantum mechanics and whatnot it's just
giving us more and more access to
what we believe is that nature of
reality so
let's talk about this you've written
about this quite a bit now i
find this subject to be
really deeply interrelated between um
consciousness and physics in the sense
that this is about
um the bottom up pan psychism and
cosmopsychism
that's that's that's occurring a
fundamental consciousness as a
universe-wide field
and that um
is is would it would it be fair to say
that
there's a there's some sort of an
abstract mathematics that are happening
you know infinitely far away and that
it's emerging
it's emerging an illusory holographic
space time i think
just just on a point of terminology yes
you alluded to bottom up
and psychism but you really meant
cosmopsychism
bottom up and psychism also called
constitutive panzygism
what they would say is that every
elementary subatomic particle is
conscious but there is no universal
consciousness
there are only gazillions of little tiny
microscopic
consciousnesses i think that's an
untenable view the only time of you is
the opposite there is only one cosmic
subject
and individual subjectivity is an
illusion which is the view i subscribe
to that would be a form of
um cosmos psychism now the mathematics
well ellen i think mathematics is how we
describe
things um the fact
that mathematical truths which are so
intuitive to us
so intuitive that it's like it's self
evidence to us it has to be true right
two plus two is four
almost by definition and there are a
number of much more subtle
nuanced mathematical truths that we are
absolutely sure are correct and and this
psychological intuition happens to apply
perfectly to the dynamics of the world
out there i mean this in itself is
extraordinary under materialistic
metaphysics because there is no
reasoning principle
why our axiomatic rules of thought
should be the rules according to which
the world out there
evolves and moves under idealism
it's not a problem because
a mind out there as well actually it's
the same mind and the division
is the separation is an illusion so uh
our axioms of thoughts those rules of of
thought that we consider self-evident
apply to the world because it's the same
mind that is behind
the world applying those same axiomatic
rules of thinking
um but then we use this fact
this this similarity between how well
this equivalence between how we think
and how
the world behaves we use it to our
advantage
to describe the behavior of the world
according to these axioms of thought and
that's that's what we call mathematics
we are describing the behavior of the
world
and what it i think ultimately informs
us
of is of how mind behaves that's what
mathematics
is telling us a mind has some
inherent patterns of behavior which a
jungian would call
archetypes of behavior unions went as
far as to say that
the axioms of mathematics were
archetypal in nature marie louise von
france
wrote a book i think in 1974
i think it's called the number and time
i i'm not sure anymore about the title
but they explore this notion
to which i subscribe the archetypes of
mind
are the um how to say
like they're the fundamental source
codes
that's one way to put it another way to
put it would be to use a vibration
analogy
you know um when you plug a guitar
string it vibrates according to one of
its
normal modes of vibration it plays
certain notes but not other
and that note depends on how long the
string is the elasticity of the string
so mind has its normal modes of
excitation once mind gets excited it
gets excited in certain ways and not in
others
so there are this archetypal
fundamental modes of behavior in mind
and i think mathematics by giving people
direct inner access to those templates
allows us to describe
from the outside as well how the world
behaves and it gives us profound hints
to what
mind is and how it comports itself
interesting so
they're to so it's more accurate to say
a bottom-up pan psychism given what
cosmo psychism currently describes
itself as but
if or you could say more accurate i
would say top-down
pencils it's a top-down pan psychism
yeah oh
interesting from from mind from from a
universal mind from
your individual mind as opposed to to
from microscopic minds to us
okay oh interesting okay interesting so
a top-down pan psychism from universal
mind to us
and but there there's a there is some
interesting
so the the feedback sort of
function isn't necessarily from an at
like an abstract mathematics that are
happening
beyond the like quantum field level
and then and they're going through this
process of the
uh unfolding and enfolding as like david
rome would say
but but it could or from this universal
uh consciousness level or this infinite
consciousness level
so it could you the idea is that it
could be doing the
on the unfolding and folding from
those seem like the same thing to me as
well this in that macro micro
sensor yeah go ahead go ahead i see how
you're visualizing it because the laws
of quantum mechanics are microscopic
laws you're thinking in terms of
the bottom up um
i understand that um
i think the way to visualize space
um is is misleading
um when you go down that path the laws
of quantum mechanics
apply to all space everywhere
yeah these are fundamental laws um
in modern physics we even don't talk
anymore about
literal particles we talk about
excitations of a field
particles are little ripples on a field
like ripples in the water there is
nothing to the ripple but the water in
the same way there's nothing to a
particle but this
feud today we still didn't manage to
reconcile
the different quantum fields so we still
talk about a set of them
but there is a very strong intuition in
physics that
they are actually all facets of one
field
and this one field is not spatially
bound
it doesn't have a size it it it is the
entire universe
i i was about to say it encompasses the
entire universe
it is the entire universe um and the
laws apply to this spatially unbound
field so even if you talk about
microscopic laws with a term that we use
because
we are not able to separate
uh and bring these laws into focus on
micro
macroscopic objects they are hidden
behind their
own interactions so to see them we need
to look at a micro
microscopic system but but this is an
artifact of
our ability to detect something
that something in itself is not
microscopic
it is the behavior the templates of
movement or vibration the archetypes
of a spatially unbound quantum field
which
is the universe the laws of quantum
mechanics are not even
local so when you talk about microscopic
laws we are just saying that we can't
discern these laws unless we look at
very tiny things
it doesn't mean that the laws are only
in the tiny things no
they are in front of you right now they
are making this screen in front of you
be able to exist and do what it does
it's just that we can't discern them at
the microscopic level
but the laws are not microscopic they
are universal
yeah okay this is a very interesting way
so like uh like an implicate or like a
source code or an infinite consciousness
or cosmic consciousness that
it would it pervades absolutely
everything
always and that it's not um
but this this part of it's this part of
it's interesting you mentioned this
um there is a sort of potentially
power law of the most
common um um abstract mathematics
the relationships that are going on and
that
those most common relationships
emerge in the holographic illusory
space-time
as the most common archetypes uh
yeah good yes okay now you hinted that
one of the most difficult topics in
science and philosophy today
we do not have consensus about how
the laws of quantum mechanics which we
discern at a microscopic level
how they somehow give rise to
the classical laws of physics like
maxwell equations newton's equations
why do these equations approximate so
well
the behavior of of the world we see and
how do they emerge from a purely
probabilistic framework
which which is what seems to apply at
the most fundamental level now
on purpose avoiding the word microscopic
i'll talk about the most fundamental
level
how does the orderliness of
macroscopic laws arise or emerge
out of the probabilistic behavior of
nature
at its most fundamental levels we do not
have a clear answer to that
there are many attempted answers i'm
right now reading an
excellent paper by a member of the
austrian academy of sciences the leader
of a
quantum physics group in the university
of vienna which i think is one of the
most
promising avenues of investigation now
we have a
cubism which is another attempt to make
sense of this
but it's an open question somehow that
probabilistic behavior
at the most fundamental level
preferentially
leads to the emergence of recognizable
regularities which we call
laws of nature
and then that leads us
into recognizable phenomenological
states
so then there's that relationship so
so in a sense we can say that
there are specific
there's a feedback mechanism that occurs
where the more that i
as my illusory individual
become more causeless joy and
imperturbable peace the more that i
become that
the more that i cause a feedback loop
to this source code
that then makes the abstract
mathematical relationships
more in the emergent direction of that
causeless piece
causes joint imperturbable piece we do
not know
if and how these feedback mechanisms
work we haven't been able to to model
them
but i think it would be extraordinarily
implausible
to say that the direction of influences
here
is only in one way points only in one
way i think it's extraordinarily
implausible i think it's
almost a virtual certainty that there
are
feedback mechanisms in operation here as
well
because we've known from complexity
sciences for instance
that it is feedback mechanisms that give
rise to complexity
and boy is this world complex so there
there should be
feedback mechanisms mechanisms operating
at every level here including
endogenous experiential states
that are providing feedback mechanisms
in a way that
we haven't been being able to model and
discern clearly yet
and we could say that then that feedback
is potentially the idea of the
co-creators
that we are these
we have a co-creative relationship with
reality this is an extraordinarily
sensitive topic
so it's so easy to be misunderstood to
be misunderstood when you talk about
this so
bear with me um there is an approach in
physics
a very conservative very level-headed
i would say unassailable approach for
interpreting quantum mechanics i would
say it's not even an interpretation
it's an acknowledgement of what quantum
mechanics is saying
which is called relational quantum
mechanics by an italian physicist called
carlo rovelli who has written a number
of
very good books and what ravelli says
is that you know if you bite the bullet
of quantum mechanics from experiments
then there is no physical quantity no
physical
entity that's absolute they're all
relative
everything that's physical is relative
to to an observer
is relative to a point of measurement
which then immediately raises the
question well if everything physical
is relative then is it relative to what
whatever it's relative to it can't be
physical otherwise you're getting to
infinite regress
right so if you understand this
you will immediately come to the
conclusion that what is really out there
is not physical it is mental and
physicality
is relative to mentality yeah
and that's how physicality arrives from
an interaction between two segments of
mind at least two
um physicality is relative to mentality
that's what quantum mechanics seems to
be
suggesting and the mentality part i
added because i think it's inevitable
it's the only other thing we know of
next to physicality
but quantum mechanics seems to be
telling us quite unambiguously
especially after
a superb experiment in 2018 that sort of
closed all loopholes
that physicality is relative relative to
what i would say it's relative to
mentality
so in so far as each person
is a observer a different observer with
a unique perspective
then your physical world is
fundamentally different from my physical
world
because my physical world is relative to
me and i'm taking a different
perspective
so we all inhabit different physical
worlds and more physical world
bear with me don't misunderstand me yet
i i have to complete this thought
so um of course we co-create our
physical world
because it's relative it arises from an
interaction between our personal
dissociated mentation
and the transpersonal mental states out
there it is from that
interaction that our physical world is
created so we co-create it we are half
of the equation
however we describe our respective
physical worlds in mutually consistent
manners you also would say well there is
a moon at night there are stars there
are trees there are cars
you know what i mean um so the
other part of the equation seems to be
transpersonal mental states in which we
are all immersed
can we change that i would say all
indications are that are that we can't
because
otherwise i would just conjure up the
world to be much better
than it is now and i seem to be unable
to do that i don't seem
to be able to create my own reality
fully
and i understand that that's not what we
are claiming either you're not saying
that we all create our own reality
you're saying that there is some degree
of influence
so i would say there's a massive degree
of influence as far as
the physicality that surrounds you is
concerned
but what ensures that your physical
world is consistent with mine and with
everybody else's
is this transpersonal ocean of mentation
that is out there
and then can we as individuals influence
that
ocean of transpersonation
i personally think very little if at all
some of the greatest minds of all time
have influenced that and made
everything much better i i
am open to that idea but then you could
say
well i influence the world in trivial
ways like um
if i use my arms and i move a rock i've
influenced the world
but what you mean is is something deeper
than that
i mean i mean michelangelo you know that
yeah okay
yeah i'll go along with that but that's
not what we mean right what we mean is
can your inner
attitude influence the physical world
through non-physical means in other
words not through the use of
perception and everything that
correlates with perception can a
thought can a inner feeling influence
something known locally
perhaps there is some evidence that this
could be the case
arising from research on so-called psi
phenomena for instance
at the university of virginia in the us
um
but i i'm tempted to think that that
influence is
rather limited let me give you another
example
on that is even something as simple as
like if we have the spectrum from you
know michelangelo to something very
simple
it can be something along the lines of
when you are with another person
especially if it's a family member or a
friend
the idea is that everything is
inextricably connected
in this knot of life and that if one
has that equanimity
that immovable peace that causes joy
just by that simple
phenomenological state can significantly
affect
what the other person's experience is
and
so that slowly in a sense um
it it takes the suffering out of the nod
of life
how is that how does it take the
suffering out because
by your phenomenological state being
that
causes joy and imperturbable peace it
butterfly effects
to the other per yeah in that in that
nod of life
all of a sudden the other person feels
your
peace and then
they themselves also take the notch down
and we all
know of the scenario where you if you go
a notch up they go a notch up and it
just poop
versus bringing it so you slowly work
out the misery and the suffering
and the needless um replaying
of the worst possible
archetypal uh phenomenologies
yeah i i this this section has been
super super interesting um
in this last bit is it is it possible to
say that
the like there is
wherever everywhere is this source code
implicate cosmic consciousness infinite
consciousness non-spatial
so non-spatial everywhere or nowhere
yeah yeah
yes okay so we have this non-spatial
um god it's everywhere um
yeah we're nowhere so so now this idea
that
from
this source code implicate etc
from there we we have a
we have a we have a power law of
the abstract mathematical possibilities
that exist and then from there it's
possible
that there is the emergence of
phenomenological states and
that we have a direct feedback
potentially
influence on that
that on those abstract mathematical
states by in
in a sense we can drive the not of life
anywhere from
a simple relationship making it better
to being
like a michelangelo or an elon musk in
trying to drive some sort of
massive artistic or technological
revolutionary change to better the world
well look um
i think what you're hinting at is is our
does our
influence extend beyond the visual or
perceptual cues that we provide i mean
you have that we had that example where
of
a discussion that escalates um you could
say well it escalates because each
participant is providing obvious visual
cues to the other he's speaking louder
his eyes are going wide open he's
gesticulating more
um but what you're hinting at if i
understand you is that
beyond the perceptual cues beyond
your physical action in the world there
is a direct
influence between your inner states and
the inner states of other people and
maybe the inner states of the universe
at large it's beyond the visual cues um
so that's correct i see you're nodding
so that my interpretation and you call
that a transpersonal ocean
well um insofar as there is a direct
influence between you and something
outside you it's going through a
transpersonal
field ocean yeah i like that yeah yeah
the drop in the ocean analogy yeah an
ocean a few these are all metaphors
you get my meaning can that be happening
i think it can it's a personal opinion
i think people who deny that that's
happening um
are in a position to deny it because
usually that happens together without
the visual cues
and and and physical effects that we
produce just by being
in the world with this you know just by
existing we displace
air we occupy a certain volume in space
so
because these things always go together
the so-called trivial
influences which are visual perceptual
cues and your physical presence in the
world
and the direct marsupial influences it's
very hard to
tease them apart so you can
categorically say that there are these
more subtle influences as
well that's why it's so difficult to
categorically say yes they exist
because it's difficult to tease them
apart from all the other things that are
happening
i think there is some research
indicating that these subtle influences
do occur um
but they are not massive because if they
were massive
i mean give you an example if
if i knew that war is about to happen i
would immediately see it meditate
concentrate and stop it from happening
but
i can't do that i can't stop world
hunger hunger i can't i can't stop
the devastation of the environment it's
happening around the world today i can't
stop people from getting sick i can't
stop my loved ones from dying from
cancer and heart attacks
so somehow
the so-called physical way of
influencing which does not entail a
direct
uh inner connection uh but just your
action in the space-time framework that
we call the physical world
those seem to be overwhelming in
relation to the more
subtle channels for for influencing
things i think
it's just an observation it's not even
an opinion it's an observation
um and that's what makes it difficult
to categorically pin down this other
thing that might be going on
and the thing is if it is going on then
it opens up a whole
lot of other degrees of freedom yeah so
it's important to know whether they are
actually going on or not
it it almost seems like a fool's errand
to try and say that it doesn't
go on in the sense that if if
if the even the the simple beautiful
imaginative idea of a rock star
electric car company that you know may
take
two decades to actually get into um
solid production worldwide does
end up that started just as that
imaginative idea
now is able to distribute tens of
thousands and more of these
um of what would what one could call the
top
quality electric vehicle across across
the planet which then
somebody else does in a sense exchange
that value of of money you know for the
the vehicle and
so then they themselves they've
basically taken what was an
imaginate imagine that imagined idea
that they themselves are now purchasing
and now it's in there
it's even something that they use every
day um
and so yeah and that same thing is true
about
basically everything and steve jobs was
one of the ones that said that you know
these
devices the phones and computers and and
but everything else as well
were literally imagined by people and
executed by people
that are just like you and so that's why
the idea is
you know there is of course a bell curve
and there are people that are extremely
conscientious um and that are
that can abstractly reason and that have
emotional intelligence to work with
teams and stuff like that versus other
people that
don't but there's all these mixes in
between and
and so people have the possibility to
make things
even incrementally better even at that
at that person level